RAHUL: Hi.
Thank you for attending.
My name is Rahul.
I do iOS and
Android at Pristine.
And Aaron Alaniz
is with me as well,
and he does Android
and Glass at Pristine.
How do I click Next?
AARON: Sorry about that.
RAHUL: OK.
So EyeSight is our
HIPAA-compliant communications
solution.
It's powered by WebRTC.
And we try to keep the
UI and user experience
with the physicians in mind.
So what does that mean?
That means minimal call
clicks and a simple call flow.
And so why did we choose WebRTC?
There's cross-platform native
support between platforms,
including Android and
wearables, and iOS and browsers.
Now I'm going to
dive into why and how
building a WebRTC client
for Android or iOS
is different than the browser.
So here's a familiar diagram
you guys have all probably seen.
The difference here is
that we replace the browser
with libjingle PeerConnection,
the JAR and the SO.
Now this is pretty much where
the difference comes in.
I'm going to go into a
little bit more detail here.
So what exactly are
we building when
we go native for
Android and iOS?
We need to compile
PeerConnection for the target
platform, either iOS or Android.
There's two parts, a mobile
layer and a native layer.
Now, the native layer consists
of stuff like libvpx, libopus,
voice and audio engine,
and bandwidth estimators.
And the mobile side,
we have setting up
the camera for the
platform, connecting
the interface and protocols.
And one thing I wanted
to mention as well
is AppRTCDemo was very, very
important for our development.
We needed to get AppRTCDemo
working correctly.
And so we need to
understand AppRTCDemo
before we can make our
own WebRTC solution.
So as I was mentioning
earlier, that we
had to make those
libjingle files,
these platform-specific
APIs are not
available for Android and iOS.
For example, there's no
Maven or CocoaPods repo
where a normal Android
or iOS user would just
expect to be there and then
just pull it down immediately.
This means we need to build the
libraries rather than expecting
the platform to support it.
And every revision change is
a pretty expensive update.
We have to retest everything.
The call might not
work after 90 minutes.
The audio might drop out.
There just could be
several problems.
So we basically have to
go through a long testing
process for each revision.
So we're very careful
when we update revisions.
So here's the WebRTC build
process that we follow through.
So if you're targeting an
Android device or an iOS
device, for Android you'll need
to install the Ubuntu build
packages, and for
iOS you'll need
to install the
Apple Xcode tools.
That's a prerequisite
for every machine.
And then after that, we'll
need to clone and pull
depot tools, which is
our git and SVN client.
WebRTC has so many
small libraries
that it's pulling from that
we'll need a git and SVN
client together to work to pull
all these products in sync.
Once we get the depot tools set
up, we'll need to sync WebRTC
by setting the target
platform to either iOS and Mac
or Android and Unix.
And then at that point,
we have an option.
We can use a custom
gclient file to add
in changes like camera or H.264.
And then we prepare WebRTC
by running gclient runhooks.
At that point, we have all
the make files there in place,
and we can run ninja
AppRTCDemo, which
will build all the native
code for AppRTCDemo.
This will ensure
that we don't try
to compile code that's not built
for the right target, which
will almost guarantee a failure.
And then you can
publish this archive
into either an Archiva
repo or CocoaPods
for an Android or iOS
developer to pull down.
Or you can just use our build
scripts that we open source.
They're really simple to use.
All you have to do
is just pull down
our GitHub repo and just
source the build script file.
And you can do build_apprtc for
Android and dance for iPhone.
For the iOS version
as well, I also
add an Xcode project that
runs AppRTCDemo with an Xcode.
So you guys don't have to worry
about all the complicated stuff
underneath the hood.
So I'm going to hand
it off to Aaron,
who's going to explain a little
bit more of the EyeSight Core.
AARON: Thanks, Rahul.
So we spent a lot of time
familiarizing ourselves
with the WebRTC repository,
the build process,
and then the artifacts that are
sort of the byproduct of that
build process.
And we didn't want to
walk away empty-handed.
So we set out to build what
we call EyeSight Core, which
is a native WebRTC wrapper
library that allows us to build
our client applications
on top of this.
My talk's going to be
mainly Android-centric,
but a lot of these
principles we used
building out the iOS
application as well.
So we set out to build the
core with a few goals in mind.
And the main goal being, how do
we solve this general problem?
How do we leverage the native
WebRTC libraries to build out
a video streaming
solution that'll
work cross-platform
natively for all devices?
And as Rahul mentioned,
we spent a lot
of time working with the
AppRTCDemo, which in our case
is an actual Android AppRTCDemo
and the iOS AppRTCDemo,
unlike the web version that's
available to a lot of you guys.
And we poured over this
code, and we broke it down
into three major components.
So we have to have a
signaling module that
handles what we call the
WebRTC dance to get a call up
and running.
And then we needed
some sort of wrappers
to interact with the
native libraries.
And then in addition
to that, we have
to build out a client-specific
UX for each platform.
So here's a bird's-eye
view of the core in action.
So it's composed
of two components.
So you have the
signaling component,
which is interacting
with our signaling server
and relaying stuff like the
ICE candidates, the offers,
the answers, and sending
them across the line.
And then we have our
PeerConnection wrapper
that mediates the communication
with our application
and with the native APIs.
And collectively,
these two work together
to push out very
client-consumable events
for each application.
So the iOS app
doesn't really care
about receiving
an ICE candidate.
It just really wants to know
about is there a call incoming?
Is my call connected?
Did they hang up?
Did the call drop?
So we wanted to abstract
all of the WebRTC dance
into very client-consumable
events that
can be built off of.
So dive a little bit further
into what's inside the core.
And as I mentioned,
the libjingle
wrapper that we have
mediates that communication
between our application
and the native libraries.
In addition to that,
since we're trying
to be very cross-platform
with our application,
we have to configure
these STP packets
for a different
context of a call.
So you might have an iOS
device calling a Glass device,
or an Android device
calling a Glass device,
or a web browser
calling a Glass device.
We handle all the
STP mangling inside
of this portion of the core.
In addition to that, probably
the most important feature
of our wrapper is that it
encapsulates the interaction
with the native
libraries in a way that's
friendly with the
Android life cycle
so that users can
opt into our app,
and they feel like they're
inside of an Android app.
They feel like they're
inside of an iOS app.
It's not just some video
streaming application.
And the signaling wrapper
is much, much simpler.
We also implement Socket.IO.
I know a lot of people
have been talking
about how they use WebSockets.
So for Android, we
use Android Async.
It's a very good, very fast
Socket.IO implementation
for Android.
And on iOS, we use AZSocketIO.
And this is much simpler.
It's just a message dispatcher.
It doesn't compose messages.
It just gets a message from
our PeerConnection wrapper
and sends it across the line.
And I want to just show
a brief example of what
I look at on a
day-to-day basis compared
to what the standard WebRTC API
looks like in the JavaScript.
And as you can see, it's
not really much different.
Clearly, don't think that
you can build something
off this right here.
It's just a short example.
But I just wanted to show the
similarities between the two.
OK, so there are a handful of
WebRTC solutions out there.
And I really wanted to
speak to our work on Glass
because I feel like that's
what really sets us apart
as a technology company.
So before that, though,
we have to talk about some
of the constraints that
come with developing
on a platform like Google
Glass, or any other wearable
device for that matter.
And some of the obvious things
are these hardware bottlenecks
that you don't really have to
think about whenever-- well,
you have to think
about a little bit,
but not definitely
as much for something
like a wearable device.
So these glasses,
you know, physicians
are walking around
their Wi-Fi networks.
And they're walking in and out
of good and bad Wi-Fi spots.
I know the guy
from that last team
made a really good comment
about most of the time
it's just a problem
with the Wi-Fi.
But they don't really care.
So we have to build around
that, especially with Glass,
because the response
time to Wi-Fi events
is definitely a little
bit more delayed
than a traditional
Android or iOS device.
In addition to that, the CPU
is a real main concern of ours.
So we use VP8 to obviously
encode and decode
frames inside our core library.
And we see great
performance between an iOS
and a regular Android
device because the CPU power
is there to do the VP8
encoding and decoding.
But we definitely see
a bottleneck effect
whenever Glass is forced to
do this sort of VP8 encoding
in software.
We are trying to work
with Glass specifically
to try and get
some H.264 support.
It's hard to guarantee any
sort of great performance
improvements.
But we have been working
with that as well.
In addition to all of
that, battery is also
a huge concern of ours
because like I said,
these devices are in
constant movement.
They're walking
from room to room.
In some cases, they're
even in an ambulance.
So we have to build
our app with the notion
that these applications
need to last all day.
And in addition to all
that-- UX limitations
for a wearable device.
It's completely different.
We have to really simplify the
application for a wearable user
so that they don't really
feel confused whenever
a call's coming in
or they're in a call.
We really want them to feel
like everything makes sense
while they're in a call.
So with that, I'm going to
talk about some features
that we built out
specifically for Glass.
Yes, I have thank
our business dev guys
because this is really good.
So I'm sure we all,
in some capacity,
are familiar with the
AppRTCDemo on the web.
And the standard demo is
showing your local video
in the top right-hand corner,
and then the remote video
gets most of the
screen real estate.
We didn't really have
a compelling use case
for showing the person calling
a Glass device's video.
In addition to that,
we didn't really
want to waste any
decoding time trying
to decode these frames coming
across the line from a client
user.
So what we decided
to do was just only
send video from Glass.
And if you're calling
a Glass device,
you don't have to worry
about sending your video.
And Glass is not even going
to receive it if you try it.
So this allows us to preserve
battery life on Glass
and build a UX that make sense.
And so, on the
left there you can
see the early
implementation of our app.
And it has a black screen
for the Glass user.
And then of course, across
the line on the other side,
you see the game of Operation.
Very quickly we found
that Glass users
want to see what
they're sending.
A good example of this
is when a surgeon's
operating in the
room, their vision
is not necessarily looking
at what is probably
the most important
part of the call.
They might be looking
straight ahead,
or they might be
looking down like this.
So we added a viewfinder
so that they can line up
their line of vision with
what's going across the line
during a call.
And to add on to that,
since we don't really
have a use case for showing
local video when you're calling
a wearable device, whenever you
call a wearable device on any
of our applications,
you get the full screen
of that wearable device.
So on the left there,
we have a nice picture
of our capital in Texas.
So you can get a feel for
the entire screen real estate
from a wearable device.
And just to juxtapose that, we
have an iOS to Android call.
And since we are
sending video both ways,
you definitely want to
show your local video
so that they can
see what they're
sending across the line.
OK, so with that, I want
to do a quick demo here.
Hopefully it goes OK.
So Rahul's got his glasses on,
and I've got my glasses on.
He's going to call
from his iOS device,
and I'm going to call
from my Glass device.
RAHUL: OK, Glass,
start EyeSight.
AARON: And as you can see, you
can share voices with Glass.
RAHUL: It's good for testing.
It's really good for testing.
AARON: All right.
So I'm calling.
And you should see a
little prompt come up.
And I apologize.
The lag is pretty
apparent whenever
you're doing Android
Screen Monitor here.
So I'm answering the call.
And there you go.
You see-- oh, I think
I lost the call here.
Anyway, on the
left there, you see
Rahul showing off
the viewfinder.
And if he actually
swipes back on the D-pad,
it'll actually disappear.
And we can use this to save
battery life in situations
where you don't really
need to line up a call.
When you slide forward,
it brings it back up.
I'm wondering what
happened to mine.
Oops.
I'm sorry.
I just took a
picture of everyone.
Wrong application.
AUDIENCE: We all
signed disclaimers.
AARON: Yeah.
Oh, interesting.
Anyways, so that's
really all I have.
I'm going to wrap it up here.
So if you're interested in
what we're doing at Pristine,
you can check out
our engineering blog
at tech.pristine.io.
We like to blog about
once or twice a month.
And at this time, I'll open
the floor for any questions.